salut aujourd'hui on est mercredi c'est
le jour de l'astuce est encore plus
qu'une astuce aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler d'un concept qui est la zone de
confort la zone de confort c'est tout
l'univers dans lequel vous évoluez vous
vivez en ce moment qu'il s'agisse de
votre travail de vos amis de votre
famille de ce que vous aimez faire de la
manière dont vous vivez de ce que vous
faites pour vous détendre tout est
inclus à l'intérieur du cercle à
l'extérieur du cercle il ya tout ce que
vous aimeriez peut-être faire dans votre
vie que ce soit des choses délirantes
comme sauter en parachute habillé en
luigi aux ambitions professionnelles et
aux ambitions personnelles
on peut d'ailleurs représentés tous à
part par d'autres petites bulles et les
croix elle symbolise le danger elle
symbolise l'inconnu elle symbolise aussi
la prise de risques mais quand vous
sortez de votre zone de confort quand
vous allez un petit peu vers l'inconnu
et que vous réussissez à faire ce que
vous aviez entrepris au départ alors
votre zone de confort augmente elle
s'élargit et c'est là le but de cette
astuce pour évoluer pour progresser pour
avancer dans quelque domaine que ce soit
je vous le dis des simples relations
amicales jusqu'aux professionnels
il faut sortir forcément de sa zone de
confort on est obligé de passer par une
étape on perd ses repères pour en
recréer des nouveaux plus large c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il faut faire des
changements progressifs il faut limiter
les risques et le but n'est pas
forcément de tout plaquer du goût du
jour en lendemain une des astuces
essentielles pour réussir à élargir sa
zone de confort c'est qu'il faut pas
trop écouter les autres ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas écouter les conseils
constructifs
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut non plus
absolument appliquer tous les conseils
qu'on vous donne mes deux bases
n'écoutez pas les gens qui veulent vous
en dissuader pour vous en dissuader en
fait ça les renvoie à leur propre image
2e qui n'osent pas prendre des risques
ça veut donc dire qu'il faut croire en
soi et même si vous n'avez pas une
confiance absolue en vous le fait de
tenter le coup et de réussir parce que
vous réussirez ça vous permettra
d'élargir votre zone aussi de prendre
confiance en vous dites vous bien que si
vous pensez à quelque chose vous faire
ce quelque chose que vous n'osez pas
sortir de votre zone de confort
quelqu'un le fera à votre place
alors pourquoi pas vous directement dans
l'absolu je vous recommande d'assumer
vos ambitions quelle qu'elle soit on a
le droit d'avoir des buts et des
objectifs dans la vie on a le droit
aussi les assumer aussi bien verbalement
que dans les actes identifier votre zone
de confort global où est ce que je vis
dans quel environnement pourquoi dans
quel but
qu'est ce que je fais pour me divertir
qu'est ce que je mange est-ce que je
pratique du sport passé tout en revue
déterminer ce qui vous ferait plaisir
d'explorer sortez de votre zone
faites votre exploration et au final
vous allez voir que vous aurez élargi
votre zone de confort l'exploration ça
peut être juste essayer d'élargir vos
activités on en pratiquant des nouvelles
ça peut être en fréquentant une nouvelle
personne d'un nouveau milieu ça peut
être aussi en déménageant peut-être même
en déménageant dans un autre pays
l'idéal pour ça c'est de se lancer des
défis et vous comprenez que c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait cette année
et je voudrais faire un parallèle sur le
mot confort et zone de confort c'est à
dire que deux bases en france on est
dans la naissance je parle dans une
belle zone de confort la plupart d'entre
nous ont un toit on a mangé ont de quoi
s'habiller dans la pyramide des besoins
on est plutôt bien placé et on peut
choisir et décider nous-mêmes de sortir
de notre zone de confort pour pouvoir
l'élargir un petit peu plus on a ce luxe
là c'est pas le cas de tout le monde si
on veut parler un petit peu de chiffres
il ya 60 millions de personnes dans le
monde qui ont été déplacés contre leur
gré qui ont été arrachées de là où ils
habitent et confort ça être un endroit
précis et qui n'ont aucun moyen de
réaliser leurs rêves leurs ambitions et
parfois même leur propre quotidien dont
30 millions d'enfants sur les 60
millions je parle d'eux c'est pas hasard
parce que le 20 juin prochain c'est la
journée mondiale des réfugiés il va y
avoir une grande campagne là dessus donc
but c'est de récolter des fonds et
évidemment mes mains en priorité par
exemple pour vous qui regardez la vidéo
de vous sensibiliser aussi à ça et à
cette réalité là en fait de 60 millions
de personnes pour qui élargir la zone de
confort voudrait dire avoir déjà une
zone de confort personnel je vous met un
lien dans le descriptif qui vous
permettra d'aller sur le site voulait
pas le préciser et puis je le précise
quand même je ne perçoit rien et ne
gagne rien à faire ça je voulais juste
vous en parler parce que je le sujet de
cette vidéo que j'avais prévu depuis un
petit moment faisait un vrai aequo avec
cette réalité là et il ya une coalition
humanitaire qui à la base est partie du
canada qui vise à aider toutes ces
familles là et c'est 60 millions de
personnes et je pense que vous l'avez
maintenant compris je soutiens à 100%
cette journée mondiale pour les réfugiés
qui a eu lieu le 20 juin et toute la
campagne qu'il ya autour donc c'était
important pour moi de vous en parler
comme ça en quelques mots pour en
terminer avec notre sujet pensez à vous
donner des défis immenses et à élargir
votre zone avoue ya une phrase qui dit
le mouvement c'est la vie géré plus loin
disant l'exploration d'autres zones
c'est la vie latham à l'eau à la fenêtre
qui me dit qu'il faut conclure j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plus que vous
allez vous donner des petits défis si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à me le faire
savoir en laissant un petit pouce en
l'air
vous pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir si ce n'est pas
déjà fait évidemment parce que le mental
blog c'est quoi c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an mais peut-être plus parce
que j'ai d'autres projets qui commence à
se dessiner pour la prochaine alors
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mentale blog ciao
non
oui